hey what's up samuel leeds and
you probably saw the video yesterday
with lauren
in manchester we were struggling with
rent to rent it was funny we were
getting rejected
hahaha it got a little bit deeper than
that and
we basically had a really bad experience
with one
agent whereby we booked a viewing we
didn't tell the agent that we're going
to be doing it as a corporate letter
it went really bad when we got to the
viewing she realized that
it was actually a corporate letter she
was really annoyed she then saw that we
were filming
she got really freaked out she was
scared she was annoyed she was
it was just dreadful i mean lawton was
um
like really embarrassed and also really
upset by it and
um we basically we basically we
basically failed the financial freedom
challenge
um the week in manchester it
don't give everyone there was some good
stuff that happened as well we did do
some deals and stuff we did some really
really good stuff
a lot of good stuff came from that week
but we failed the financial freedom
challenge we didn't make secure a single
rental ran
um it's the first time that i've ever
felt like giving up
um drawing during the challenge it was
just tough i think it was a combination
of the lock down and different things so
anyway why am i doing this video because
i've got all the footage i've literally
got the footage of lauren
um and myself having a conversation late
at night i think he was on the third
night
where he's just like i can't we do this
anymore
um i'm literally crying on the video
because i just felt so um
i just felt so bad that it hadn't worked
out because lauren was relying on me
coming to his house to help him become
financially free and it'll be wonderful
um so yeah basically why am i doing this
video because
i lauren's happy for me to release the
footage he's cool and as i say there was
some good stuff that happened as well in
the week it wasn't all bad
we just failed the financial freedom bit
um
so my thinking is i've seen some of the
footage
i might even put i could eat i can i i'm
happy to put it out i just what i don't
want to do is i don't want to demoralize
people either i don't want to put
footage out
of me and like me who's financially free
multi-millionaire and moving someone's
house and that's just failing to do rent
to rent
getting rejected i don't want like the
message to be that
it's not possible because jeez if i
can't even do it if i can't even go to
manchester and get a rent to rent
then what message does that send to
people that i'm trying to inspire i'm
trying to help i'm trying to
create more success students if i failed
what does that say it almost gives
people an excuse to fail which is the
exact opposite of what i intended to do
um could i go and do it again in
manchester and get a financial freedom
challenge completed and
and and secure a renter in and it all
worked out happily ever after
probably i don't know if it was locked
down i don't know if it was
lauren's the top guy lauren's incredible
in fact lauren i think he's probably the
strongest contestant of the whole
throughout the whole of the eviction and
um
what do you want what do you think what
do you suggest i want to be really real
i want to be authentic i want to be
transparent i want to tell you how it
went how did he go
i think there was some really good stuff
i'm happy to put the whole thing out
so tomorrow i might even post tomorrow
the moment of
uh basically that's just quitting on red
to ranch and just quit
i might even put that moment it was very
sad it's very emotional i might put that
out for tomorrow
um we're planning on putting the whole
documentary out on
tuesday tuesday at 7 p.m
let me know do you want to see it do you
want do you want to see it
or should i just uh do it again from
scratch
let me know in the comments i'll see you
soon